if you're a web developer be prepared to
have your mind blown did you know it
takes longer to say www than it does to
just say world wide web and that one
little change could add hundreds of
milliseconds to your productivity had I
known that 15 years ago I'd probably
have my own space exploration Company by
now but instead I'm still just building
crappy websites speaking of which while
we've all been distracted by the
terrifyingly overhyped rise of
artificial intelligence the web platform
has landed some game-changing new
features that you probably haven't heard
of yet and will change the way we build
websites forever and that's not even
hyperbole the first feature on this list
is huge the native HTML dialogue I first
mentioned this feature about a year ago
but now it's fully supported on all
major browsers and what it does is make
it way easier to build your own modal
Windows normally to build a modal from
scratch you need a full screen backdrop
then a window that sits on top of it and
a bunch of hacked together JavaScript to
show and hide these elements it's always
felt way harder than it should be but
now we have the dialogue which is just a
regular HTML element that you can
reference by its ID and has a few
built-in JavaScript methods to show and
hide it for example to show them modal
we can run the show modal method and it
magically appears in the UI with a
backdrop the backdrop itself has its own
pseudo element that can be styled with
CSS we can then close the modal by
either submitting a form inside of it
with a method of dialog or by calling
its close method on some other event
this makes life so much easier because
you can animate it using simple CSS
Transitions and speaking of making your
life easier today's sponsor is clerk who
provides the most beautiful user
authentication solution I've ever seen
by dropping a few components into your
favorite full stack framework you get a
professional UI that can handle a
variety of different sign-in methods
like passwords magic links social
sign-on and multi-factor off once signed
in developers can easily access the
current user from both front end and
back-end environments in addition clerk
provides the UI for users to customize
their own data and handles Advanced
security requirements like session
management per device features that
could take weeks to roll out on your own
and the UI is fully customizable I had a
lot of fun switching from retro to
neo-brutalism these components can be
dropped into any react framework and
play well with popular back ends like
Firebase and has a free tier up to 5000
users give it a try with the link below
native modal windows are great but
another feature that's annoying to
implement is the popover luckily native
popovers are also coming to the web as
of today this feature is experimental so
you'll need to enable it with a flag but
basically it provides a couple of
attributes like pop over Target and
popover which allows you to show and
hide content without the need to write
any JavaScript or tricky CSS that uses
Focus within just match the element ID
to the popover Target and you're done
that'll be a nice quality of life
Improvement but the next feature web GPU
is easily the most important feature on
this list even if you never use it it's
basically the successor to webgl
allowing browsers and web applications
to take advantage of gpus it is under an
experimental flag today but many
libraries like babylonjs fully supported
already and support for 3js is underway
and that means 3D graphics and games are
about to get way faster on the web I'm
using it right now with Babylon JS and
as you can see the web GPU version is
far more Majestic and not just that but
libraries like tensorflow.js support it
which means develop will be able to
build web apps where end users can train
machine learning models without the need
to download a bunch of python libraries
or use a notebook in the cloud that's
pretty cool but for most web developers
the biggest challenge is writing good
CSS next on the list we have container
queries to build responsive websites
developers often use media queries where
you apply different styles to an element
based on the size of the viewport the
problem is that in many cases you're not
worried about the viewport but you're
worried about the parent container of an
element and that's always been really
hard to deal with until now with
container queries you first create a
containment context with a container
type property then from there you can
use the container app rule which can
apply different styles based on the
nearest ancestor container in addition
there are a bunch of new units like
container query width and height that
allow you to compute the proper size of
the children directly in the CSS in the
past you might run into situations where
you have to actually get the bounding
box from JavaScript then solve some
crazy differential equations you get the
div in the right place and you'll be
happy to know that there's an official
Tailwind container queries package that
allows you to declare these containers
directly in your HTML another cool CSS
feature you might not know about is
color mix I've used tools like SAS to
mix colors in the past but now we can do
it natively in CSS it's a function that
takes two color arguments and mixes them
in a specified color space like in this
example if we mix red and blue in an RGB
color space we get purple as a result
that's not very useful on its own but it
makes it easier to do effects like this
where I have a list of items that mix
red and white together to create a
gradient effect that occurs over
multiple elements but speaking of
features from SAS another huge one is
CSS nesting I can't believe it's taken
this long but it's almost fully
supported in all modern browsers it's
purely an ergonomic feature that allows
you to write Styles in a far more
concise and readable Way by nesting them
inside a parent just like a kangaroo in
a pouch which eliminates tons of
duplicated class names from your code
but another very interesting new feature
is color fonts also known as chromatic
fonts that use multiple colors inside of
a single glyph this opens up a whole new
world of possibilities because now you
can customize the entire color palette
of a font and create some crazy effects
like 3D gradients what's cool about this
is that they're still interpreted as
regular fonts in the browser whereas
previously stuff like this would only be
possible with your own custom vector
graphics there are only a few color
fonts at the moment but it will be
interesting to see what else comes out
in the future but the next thing I want
to look at is performance and the new
web vitals plugin for Chrome you can
measure the performance of any website
by running a lighthouse report but the
process is kind of slow and cumbersome
this plugin will console log performance
metrics as you use a website and it can
pinpoint performance issues like layout
shift and point you to the exact element
that's causing the problem there's a ton
of things to consider when it comes to
Performance and I have a full video on
that topic on my second Channel if you
want to learn more but now it's time to
talk about some new JavaScript features
like array at if you come from a
language like python or most other
languages for that matter you might find
it absurd that to get the last element
in a JavaScript array you have to take
the array length and subtract one you
can't just use negative one or last
until now because at makes this code
obsolete now we can just say at negative
one to get the last element or second to
last with negative two that's pretty
cool but deep copy is even more useful
one thing you'll eventually have to do
is copy an object in JavaScript objects
are passed by reference which means if
you assign one to a new variable you're
still going to reference the same
original object if you modify a property
on B it will also modify the property on
a because they're the same object
reference now most of the time we use
object assign or the spread syntax to
create a new object but the problem here
is that it only does a shallow copy and
that means if an object has any nested
objects on it those nested objects will
still maintain the reference to their
original object but in many cases that's
not what you want and what developers
have been doing for years is using Json
stringify to turn the object into a
string and then Json parse to parse it
back into an object that's a completely
ridiculous hack that creates a new
object reference in memory but I'm happy
to report that life doesn't have to be
this way there's now a global function
called structured clone that can clone
an object into a new reference making it
way easier to transfer data from one
object to another and that gives us 10
awesome new web features to take
advantage of but wait there's more like
the transform stream interface that
allows you to pipe one fetch call into
another or how about import maps that
allow you to declare a bunch of
JavaScript modules all at once and I
didn't even mention that there's a tc39
proposal that will allow you to import
Json directly into a Javascript file in
the future oh and let's not forget that
we also now have individual CSS
transform properties allowing you to
modify scale translation and rotation
more easily and we have new trigonomic
functions in CSS like sine cosine and
tangent which is incredibly useful if
you have circles in your design we also
now have a CSS initial letter property
which you might use to make the first
letter in an article bigger just like in
a magazine I should also probably
mention new viewport units designed
specifically for mobile that can take
into account if toolbars are opened or
not Also let's not forget Focus visible
which is a more accessibility friendly
way to handle focus and form inputs and
buttons speaking of focus there's also
now an inert property that you can use
on elements to show they lack the
ability to move or be focused on that
one's kind of boring but a way more
exciting experimental technology is the
view transitions API which allows
developers to create animations between
web pages you make websites behave more
like mobile apps that keep the user in
context and finally we have animation
timeline as of today it's experimental
but it gives you the ability to control
animations based on the scroll position
in the browser a feature that everybody
does but always feels way more
complicated than it should be and with
that we've looked at 21 new features on
the web if you knew every single one of
them congratulations you just won the
grand prize one free web development job
redeemable at the company of your
choosing just present this certificate
during your interview and they should
let you write in no questions asked
thanks for watching and I will see you
in the next one